so i want to start today with something
that gives me great pleasure it's video
of our friend congressman jamie raskin
who appeared on this program not long
ago and who i think is doing an
excellent job
basically making a fool out of
republican congressman thomas massey
because massey sees conspiracies
everywhere now in particular in this
clip
it's all about ray epps now if you
haven't heard about ray epps i'm going
to tell you about him in a moment but
it's important that you know before we
look at the clip
there are some on the right
who believe
that an individual named ray epps who
appeared in washington dc on january 5th
in some videos
is either an agent or an asset or an
informant of the fbi
who
essentially encouraged trumpists to do
what they did on january 6th and that
the entire thing was staged slash
encouraged
by the fbi there is no evidence for this
whatsoever republicans some are obsessed
with it
and jamie raskin in this clip rightly
points out to massey
why is everything a conspiracy to you
and take a look at the first few seconds
alone are extremely informative
mr epps was in front of the january 6
committee and we were told that a
transcript of his interview would be
released but it's never been released
and i wondered was he sworn none of the
transcripts have been released so you
don't need a conspiracy theory about
that we haven't released anything were
you present so the on this is such it's
it's just the beginning of this clip but
it's so important a lot of these right
wingers
love to say
hey but what about this this is
suspicious
and oftentimes this is just the way
things are done and so in this case
massey says
you haven't released the transcript from
when we spoke to ray epps and jamie
raskin says we've done a thousand
interviews we haven't released any
transcripts there's nothing special
about ray epps it's sort of like when uh
republicans claim voter fraud
and you say okay well what
what is the basis for that claim
and they say well
the pictures of every scanned ballot
haven't been released to us
that's never done in any state even
states where the margin of victory is
massive that's not that's not something
that's a red flag okay let's continue
when he was interviewed that'll give me
no i was not i was not we've done more
than a thousand interviews you guys are
trying to make this poor schmuck who
showed up to your protest into something
a lot bigger than he is
okay he's just trying to survive and
he's on your side you don't have many
voters left you might want to try to
hang on to them without demonizing and
vilifying your own people isn't that
good that's the donald trump way so
everybody else down the road
unless you're gonna get a pardon some
people are still hanging around waiting
for their pardon
but
most people have opened their eyes about
what he's done to our country
what he's done to his family have you
guys ever read the book by mary trump
about the way that donald trump has
absolutely destroyed their family
wrecked her father's life
they do it to family they do it to
friends they do it to their own
associates and employees and now you
guys are doing it to this poor ray apps
leave that guy alone whoever he is
so very nicely done by jamie raskin and
they love to see conspiracies everywhere
even when there are none there's a
really good factcheck.org article about
the entire ray epps thing the quick take
is
reyes was at the capitol
but there is no evidence he was an fbi
plan
uh there is evidence that epps once held
a leadership role in the oath keepers
some of whose members have been charged
in the attack ray epps is a 60 year old
he owns a wedding venue in phoenix
arizona the fbi put a picture of him on
a list of people they were seeking
information about
and the conspiracy theories about ray
epps include he just doesn't really seem
like a random insurrectionist he seems
more like law enforcement the other
circumstantial claim that's made by some
trumpists is he was on a list of people
the fbi wanted to talk to
and suddenly he was off the list well
maybe it's because the fbi found him and
talked to him everything is a conspiracy
with these people and they should be
ridiculed the way that jamie raskin did
i saw a funny comment on twitter that
thomas massey really has
milton from office space
vibes you know the guy who
uh where is where is my stapler but
that's my that's my favorite stapler it
is very accurate there is that exact
vibe to thomas massey and ray epps
raskin calls him a poor schmuck
maybe i wouldn't go that far
uh but he's certainly a right winger and
he was certainly in washington dc on
january fifth sixth and he certainly is
not an fbi plan hey uh a couple months
ago i interviewed this trump endorsed
republican uh house candidate j.r
majewski we spoke about a lot of things
with j.r majewski in some areas he was
quite radical and others he was not
quite so radical but we have now learned
that j.r majewski has completely
fabricated his supposed record as a
military veteran who served in
afghanistan
multiple times this is stolen valor
folks
multiple times j.r majewski has said i
did serve in afghanistan it turns out
that he didn't
this was if i understand correctly
broken by the associated press
uh in which brian sladisko and james
laporta wrote
j.r majewski presents himself as an air
force air force combat veteran deployed
to afghanistan after 9 11 once
describing quote tough conditions
including a lack of running water
forcing him to go more than 40 days
without a shower
military documents obtained by the ap
tell a different story majeski never
deployed to afghanistan he did six
months loading planes at an air base in
qatar
that's an ally
it was very safe from any fighting
majewski's account of his time in the
military is only one aspect of his bio
that's suspect his post-military career
has been defined by exaggerations
conspiracy theories talk of violent
action against the u.s government and
occasional financial duress
thanks to an unflinching allegiance to
trump he also stands a chance of
defeating the long-time democratic
congresswoman marcy kapter now listen
this guy is out of his mind and we knew
that from the interview i did with him
he has no business being a member of the
house
i hope
that these lies yes this is stolen valor
i hope that these lies about his
military service
end up torpedoing his campaign he should
he should just drop out he probably
won't let's take a look at some clips
here is j.r majewski claiming that he
did a tour of duty in afghanistan but he
doesn't really like to talk about it
what a humble guy huh did you serve in
afghanistan yes he did
did you serve in afghanistan yes i did
that is a lie
that is a lie
okay i'm just going to play it once more
so that there's no ambiguity here about
whether he lied
did you serve in afghanistan yes i did
how many tours
one
what what year were you there what years
uh 2000
2002 2003.
wow so you served right right at the
beginning yeah was that experience like
um
tough
tough i don't like talking about my milk
it was really tough when he was in
afghanistan
never happened just a lie
it's very experienced not not that um
not that we've said too much i just
don't
i don't really like to
i really don't like to divulge a lot of
things about the military because you
know they're to me
you know it was a
it was a tough time in
life um
you know the military wasn't easy but
in retrospect it's one of the best
decisions i've ever made
it it's a lie folks
he loaded planes in qatar for six months
that's what he did there was no tough
experience in afghanistan now as far as
his claim that he didn't shower for 40
days
maybe that's true but it certainly
wasn't because there was no running
water here's another example of this
wherein he says that he
uh he he it's something it's it's a
really detailed story about playing
video games in afghanistan
he was never in afghanistan it's just a
lie xbox and i'd be on that thing to
like midnight just
talking [ __ ] and shooting people man it
was fun
but i also remember now that i'm
thinking about that um
but yeah we played the division man for
forever and then the division two game
came out and we just kind of got
we just you know we played it for like a
month or two and it wasn't the same so
we we quit but
um
i remember being in the desert man right
in afghanistan and uh
that is a lie
he was not in afghanistan
um
somebody's mom sent
um a playstation 2 or something like
that over with grand theft auto
and
anyway you get the point so the point is
he was playing video games when he was
in afghanistan and then there's a whole
bunch of these a whole bunch of these
examples of him uh just lying here's
another one
did she serve in the military
no she uh and you did you you were air
force okay you served in operation
enduring freedom correct
absolutely afghanistan yes sir
yes sir
in afghanistan it's just another lie and
i could even find uh find find more of
these um and they are quite despicable
in fact just to be thorough
there was one more here uh yeah here he
actually he says he lost his grandmother
when he was in afghanistan i have no
regrets with my life one or two
and um those those regrets are you know
if i could do them over
um it would be things that i didn't know
i could have controlled
you know yeah but you know you know the
most important thing that's ever
happened probably is i lost my
grandmother when i was in afghanistan
and i didn't i didn't get to see her
that that he wasn't in afghanistan now
did he lose his grandmother while he was
in qatar maybe but that's a totally
different story that's not combat
so by the standards of republicans
this guy should be forced to drop out
not a single republican should be voting
for this guy republicans claim that we
should revere our veterans now of course
they don't do it we don't even provide
good medical care in many cases to our
veterans although the va does the best
it can
we really leave behind veterans in many
ways when it comes to jobs as well but
forget about the fact that they don't
really mean it
stolen valor
should be the end of the road for these
republicans and yet j.r majewski might
still win his race horrible stuff and
really good reporting by the ap and
others
figuring out that this guy apparently
made up the entire thing let me know
what you think find me on twitter at
deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
remember that the david pakman show is a
community and audience funded program
you can support the work we do through
the membership program and you can sign
up at joinpackman.com the list of
benefits is extensive but at the top of
the list
is the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad every
day
we do an extra show for our members and
i encourage you to sign up at
joinpacman.com
major major major news yesterday donald
trump and his family are getting sued
new york yes they are suing trump
and the case is being referred to the
internal revenue service the irs for
criminal prosecution this is this is
really important the key detail here is
this is totally separate from the fbi
search warrant this is unrelated this is
a totally different thing as the legal
problems are stacking up up up higher
and higher to the moon for donald trump
and his family this relates to the
fraudulent representations of asset
values exactly as our friend michael
cohen testified about
and will talk to us about when he joins
us later this month on the program
cnbc article new york sues trump company
and family members over widespread fraud
claims seeking at least 250
million dollars in penalties new york
attorney general leticia james sued
trump
trump org as well as eric don jr and
ivanka for allegedly widespread fraud as
trump says involving false financial
statements related to the company
mr trump's statements of financial
condition from 2011 to 2021 were
fraudulent and misleading in both their
composition and presentation that's cnbc
patch.com
explains more
about what is believed that donald trump
and his family did
claiming money that you do not have does
not amount to the art of the deal said
laetitia james in the civil suit
wednesday james says trump repeatedly
and grossly inflated the value of
properties in a long-standing game of
smoke and mirrors
so
i'll explain the gist of this and i
think to summon our audience you already
know this but it's worth explaining
what is the point
of saying a property you have is worth
more or is worth less than it really is
and it has to do with
are you trying to get a loan using that
property as collateral
or are you trying to avoid property
taxes
on a particular property let's say i
have not a perfect building in new york
but a nice building and it's worth 10
million dollars in reality now in
reality
trump's defenses that property values
are subjective and of course that's true
but let's say that on average
independent appraisers say a building is
worth 10 million dollars if you need a
15 million dollar loan
the 10 million dollar building is not
going to suffice as collateral in
general you can get
generally speaking 80 percent loan to
value meaning for a 10 million dollar
building you can only get a loan of 8
million dollars against it so in order
to justify the 15 million loan trump can
say this this is a great building this
is a 20 million dollar building and now
that would enable him if the bank
believes it to give him a 15 loan
against it so that's when you inflate
the asset value on the other hand
in comes the property tax collector the
real estate uh tax collector and says
you've got a 10 million dollar building
here
you owe us money for property taxes
based on 10 million and then trump can
make a completely different case and say
no listen the toilets aren't so good you
got to flush them 10 to 15 times as
trump often complains about and uh you
know jared kushner is evicting people
and all these different things it's not
worth 10 million it's only worth 5
million so tax me on the 5 million it's
a type of fraud
and it relates to keeping two sets of
books and it relates to a whole bunch of
other accounting and different types of
fraud so this
is the crux of it now we've got a couple
of videos here from the attorney general
leticia james and she has quite a bit to
say about all of this
mr trump also blatantly ignored legal
restrictions at mar-a-lago
mar-a-lago was valued on the false
premise that it sat on
unrestricted property and could be
developed for residential use
however
mr trump knew that mar-a-lago was
subject to a host of onerous
restrictions and limitations
mr trump himself signed deeds sharply
restricting changes to the property and
donating his residential development
rights in an effort to get a tax
deduction and later to lower his
property
taxes on the property exactly the deeds
also require mr trump to donate over 23
percent of mar-a-lago's value to the
historic trust for historic preservation
if he ever sold it
despite these significant restrictions
mr trump valued the property based on
the false premise that it was an
unrestricted residential 18 acre
plot of land that could be sold and used
as a private home
in fact the valuations represent that
these restrictions
don't even exist
the club generated annual revenues of
less than 25 million dollars
and should have been valued at more than
valued at about 75 million dollars
however
mar-a-lago
was valued
as high as
739 million dollars
bit of an exaggeration that's for sure
and leticia james they're outlining just
more examples of the type of thing that
i'm talking about now what is she
seeking well in addition to 250 million
dollars in damages her goal is to
prohibit any of trump's companies from
doing business in the state of new york
and lastly
to cancel any certificate filed under
and by virtue of the provisions of
section 130 of the general business law
for the corporate entities named as
defendants
and any other entity controlled by or
beneficially owned by donald trump which
participated in or benefited from the
ongoing financial scheme
in other words
permanently prohibit
any of these companies
from doing business
in the state of new york now we don't
know whether any of these things are
going to happen we don't know whether a
single dollar is going to be collected
here in this lawsuit we don't know
whether trump and his family will
actually be barred from doing business
in new york but what we do know is that
the legal problems are mounting and the
legal bills are exploding dramatically
here now donald trump is of course on a
tirade about this and we'll get to that
in a moment but understand that these
are mechanisms
which
anyone in a sense could could try to
take advantage of if you have a house
that's worth 300 000
you could try to get a favorable
favorable appraisal if you want to get a
home equity line of credit
and you could also call the local tax
assessor and say the property is
terrible it's not worth that much to
lower your property taxes a little bit
but we're talking about thousands of
dollars there here we are talking about
tens if not hundreds of millions of
dollars
that impact dramatically
tax collections and loan money that is
put at risk by financial corporations
this is very serious it should be taken
seriously we are going to follow where
this goes two
points that have been made about why it
will be difficult for letitia james to
prevail in this lawsuit
number one
there is a disclaimer that is included
in these valuation documents by the
trump organization which says
property valuations are subjective now
whether that is
enough to clear someone of fraud
liability is going to have to be
investigated but one claim is we say
this is subject to uh um
it is subjective period um and then
number two
proving that donald trump really meant
to deceive and that he was even
personally involved all of these are
obstacles certainly to holding trump
accountable but the legal problems
mounting and donald trump completely
exploding about this
within minutes of yesterday's
announcement that new york attorney
general letitia james is suing trump and
his family for 250 million dollars and
seeking to bar his organization from
doing business in new york over multiple
instances of alleged fraud donald trump
took to his failed social media platform
truth social also known as truth central
to trump
and
viciously attacked letitia james
not defending himself on the merits but
just attacking letitia james let's take
a look at a few of these posts donald
trump starting with quote
another witch hunt by a racist attorney
general leticia james who failed in her
run for governor getting almost zero
support from the public and now is doing
poorly against law and order attorney
general candidate highly respected
michael henry
i never thought this case would be
brought until i saw her really bad poll
numbers implying it's all political she
is a fraud who campaigned on a get trump
platform despite the fact that the city
is one of the crime and murder disasters
of the world under her watch
trump continuing attorney general
leticia peek-a-boo james i don't have no
clue what peek-a-boo is all about a
total crime-fighting disaster in new
york is spending all of her time
fighting for very powerful and
well-represented banks and insurance
companies who were fully paid made a lot
of money and never had a complaint about
me instead of fighting murder and
violent crime which is killing new york
state she is a failed attorney general
whose lack of talent in the fight
against crime is causing record numbers
of people and companies to flee new york
bye-bye
and then lastly trump continuing his
attack
not defending himself on the charges but
just attacking the messenger
the new york times her peek-a-boo james
case against him could be difficult to
prove property valuations are often
subjective and the financial statements
include a very strong disclaimer
thank you
so this is going to be a fight but it is
problem after problem for donald trump
and i'll be i'll be perfectly frank with
you
i don't know whether trump plans to run
for president in 24.
i don't know whether trump believes that
running for president will somehow
insulate him from the repercussions of
all of these legal problems the people
doing the prosecution say it will not
but it remains to be seen
but it is increasingly looking like it's
going to be really difficult
to run for president at the same time
that there are so many legal problems
that you were facing we'll see what
ultimately happens and all of these
clips that i played for you are
available on our instagram which you can
find by searching instagram for david
pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show i am going to play for
you now clips from the most humiliating
deranged and disastrous interview that i
can ever remember donald trump giving
since the start of his political career
trump seems visibly scared in this
interview this interview took place last
night on fox news with sean hannity
after the news that new york was suing
trump and his family for 250 million and
seeking to prevent him from doing any
business in new york after
trump's own special master said you got
to cut the crap because these
explanations aren't cutting it and after
a judge determined that yes the
department of justice can now resume its
investigation of trump with the
documents they seized at mar-a-lago
trump is scared
and when trump gets scared he becomes
belligerent belligerent without even
drinking
let's get right into this trump missing
from fox news for a while allowed back
on
and before we even get into the criminal
stuff trump continuing this impossible
to understand statement that he both
completed the wall and was just about to
finish it when he left office came along
and they just dismantled that they
wouldn't finish the wall the wall was
completed the original section was
completed i said let's do more we did
more he could have that finished in
three weeks okay
the wall was done
but then they stopped it
but we had completed it
and then they said we could do it in
three weeks
i can't even make sense of that so i'm
not even going to try let's just
continue here is donald trump addressing
this issue
of the
values of his properties
see if you can make sense of this and
she said we're going to get him that her
whole campaign was based on that
and then she came after us we've been
going over this for years
and i actually thought because our
values are
really high the company is great i built
a great company you take places like
this so many other places that i have
like this frankly i mean just the the
among the finest places anyway he can't
even address the substance just he gets
locked into this my places are great in
the world i actually thought that they
would never bring a case and she brought
it and the reason i thought because she
didn't have a case
i was of the impression she wanted to
settle but i had a problem because how
do you pay something
even if it's a small amount of money if
you're not guilty this was
he thought she was gonna just i mean
it's completely unintelligible folks
i thought we were just gonna settle with
her instead but also how do you do
guilty when you didn't do anything wrong
and but why were you expecting to settle
then you but what are you talking about
it doesn't make any sense
this continues to just get worse and
worse trump unable to answer any
question directly asked by sean hannity
were you actually the one filling out
the loan applications
i don't think trump even answers that
question go back to leticia james did
you ever in your life fill out a loan
application running the trump
organization
well you know we make loans but i have
very little debt
well the question was do you fill out
the applications here's what i want to
tell you about
i might add one thing
they've demeaned me for years with this
stuff and now they find out i have very
little debt very he doesn't answer the
question okay the question was do you
fill out the loan apps and trump goes i
don't have much debt and you know we
make loans but who knows
here hannity actually seems to try to
help trump come up with possible legal
defenses
they're not great ideas i have to tell
you i was told that in your financial
statements when you make a loan
application and you can confirm or if
you know this or not know this do you
put in a caveat that actually says these
are our valuations because i don't know
a lending institution a bank a financial
institution that would lend money to
anybody and just go by the borrower's
estimation evaluation of a particular
property so if you're buying a 100
million dollar property and you're
putting x y and z up for leverage you
estimate its value with this they
estimate it at this right don't they
have a fiduciary responsibility before
you they give you that amount of money
so what they determine what the value is
these are banks that have the best law
firms in the world the biggest and best
and most powerful they do their own work
they don't rely on us but what they do
is we have a disclaimer and we put so
understand the subterfuge
whether or not that not that is true and
it is true generally speaking that
that's that banks do that
it doesn't make it any less fraudulent
for trump to put a bunch of this stuff
on paper in the way that he did as
outlined in the 200-page lawsuit either
my people put it together i would
look at it and it looked fine but it's
not overly important what's important is
the property i have the best property
what happened sean is we have a
disclaimer right on the front
and it basically says you know get your
own people you're at your own risk this
was done by management it wasn't done by
it was done by management so don't rely
on the statement that you're getting
and it's and by the way it goes on for
like a page and a half it's a very big
disclaimer it's a very powerful
disclaimer super powerful guys it's
nobody's ever seen a disclaimer this
powerful to be to be completely honest
um trump then continues to argue
he
he's almost continuing to argue the
false real estate values that are at the
crux of the lawsuit he just keeps saying
these are the values after saying well
it's subjective so even if it's worth
less it's not really my problem now he
says well these are the values ability
to come up with their own valuation
because they've got their own bosses and
shareholders that they have to answer to
so they would look at a property like
this i don't even have a mortgage on
this property i don't have a mortgage on
most of my properties okay i actually i
want to address that for a second
you and i might say
you either have a mortgage on a property
or you own it outright
in these
big commercial properties hotels and
resorts and this type of thing
saying i don't have a mortgage
versus i don't have debt are two
different things because in these types
of properties sometimes they are
financed with debt to equity financing
it's not a mortgage a mortgage is not
the instrument sometimes you would have
a commercial loan sometimes it's a
commercial construction loan because
you're buying a property for 50 million
and you need another 25 million for work
and so you need 75 million and you put
down 10 percent it's not a mortgage
strictly speaking they're not mortgages
but it is still debt and so that all of
these little statements
are
misdirections at their core you know i
used to read where i was overextended
and he had so much money to borrow and
i'm saying what are they talking about
but
and actually the one good thing is
people see what a great company i built
i built a great company a powerful
company you're getting sued for lying
and he's talking about his company a
company that's very lowly leveraged with
the among the best assets anywhere in
the world i mean you look at this asset
she has this down to 75 million dollars
i can tell you it's
many times that number she said oh he
valued it at 75 or whatever
she valued at 75. he doesn't even know
what he's saying this by the way
mar-a-lago what they're talking about is
mar-a-lago which leticia james believes
is worth 75 million and trump believes
is worth
worth 739
million does leticia james know but if i
were going i don't have a mortgage on
this forever if i was going to put a
mortgage on this property the
institutions are going to be coming over
they're going to go through comparable
properties all over palm beach or
whatever it is wherever it may be miami
we have them all over we have tremendous
properties so he's completely all over
the place then it starts to get almost a
little bit sad where trump admits he has
trouble referring himself to himself as
a former president
when they're here we could do
lots of things we i think we had good
security we had as you know we had
tremendous secret service they are
unbelievable people
and they're all over mar-a-lago as
happens to a former president etc cetera
i hate to use the word former because i
have a lot of problems with what
happened but the fact is we wouldn't be
having all these problems that we have
right now by the way with ukraine and
russia talking about nuclear this has
nothing to do with ukraine and russia
your weapons now i want to get to all of
that because what's happening in the
world is horrible
it's a it's a horrible thing what's
happening in the world at another point
during the interview trump again went
back to the fbi planted evidence at
mar-a-lago now that is old ground which
i thought he had gotten away from by
saying they didn't plant it it was
totally fine for me to have it but i
guess we're going back to maybe it was
planted when hillary broke him up broke
up all her phones with the hammers and
they did the police fit
oh god now the story is hillary with a
hammer smashing up trump's iphone all
the things that happened were incredible
well you could also say 33 million
documents or pages
with president obama that's very
questionable 33 million 33 000
happens to be a similar number 33
million
that's suspicious guys 33 a lot of 33
going on they're fighting over them or
arguing over them
the problem that you have is they go
into rooms they won't let anybody near
that they wouldn't even let them in the
same building
did they drop anything into those piles
there it is there's the suggestion the
fbi could have dropped any of that stuff
which i by the way declassified why
would you declassify the very things the
fbi is planning to leave there
then maybe the whack the second wackiest
moment of this interview
trump says he can declassify documents
telepathically
by thinking about it
folks please stand it you know there's
different people say different things
but as i understand it doesn't have to
be if you're the president of the united
states you can declassify just by saying
it's declassified even by thinking about
it right because you're sending it
to mar-a-lago or to wherever you're
sending it and
there doesn't have to be a process there
can be a process but there doesn't have
to be so
trump can telepathically declassify
documents
but he didn't take them they might have
been planted by the fbi and it just so
happened that they had been
telepathically declassified by donald
trump
here is the final moment from this
interview
and
it is so
unintelligible trump is on a word salad
that is so unintelligible that about a
minute in
hannity
tries to
stop trump to help him
because what he's saying is making so
little sense
and even hannity can't save trump so let
me ask you this question because i i
think this is the next logical question
because the president of the united
states you unlike say hillary clinton in
her case right a president has the power
to declassify correct okay you have said
on truth social a number of times you
didn't decline i didn't read last year
okay
is there a process what was your process
to deal with it doesn't have to be a
process as i understand it you know
there's different people say different
things but as i understand that doesn't
have to be if you're the president of
the united states you can declassify
just by saying it's declassified even by
thinking about it because you're sending
it
to mar-a-lago or to wherever you're
sending it and
there doesn't have to be a process there
can be a process but there doesn't have
to be all right so that's what we saw
before and now it goes off the rails and
within 30 seconds hannity tries to help
and even he can't save trump doesn't you
make that decision so when you send it
it's declassified we
i declassified everything now i
declassified things and we were having a
lot of problems with nara you know nara
uh is a radical left group of people
running that thing and when you send
documents over there
i would say there's a very good chance
that a lot of those documents will never
be seen again
there's also a lot of speculation
because of what they did the severity of
the fbi you're coming in and raiding
mar-a-lago
were they looking for the hillary
clinton emails that were deleted but
they are around some place were they
looking for the response
no no they may be saying they may have
thought that it was in there okay and a
lot of people said the only thing is
trump saying
the fbi might have thought
hillary's bleached emails
were at mar-a-lago i i can't tell you
what he's saying it would give the kind
of severity that they showed by actually
coming in and raiding with many many
people is
the hillary clinton deal the
russia-russia-russia
stuff or
i mean there are there are a number of
things the spying on trump's campaign
folks this guy is scared in a way i've
never seen him be scared
i think that's the explanation here the
behavior the delusions the unhinged
nature there is something materially
different here
and i believe it's that trump is scared
out of his wits
let me know we will have this clip on
our facebook page we will have it on our
instagram i want to hear from
you follow us on social media interact
with the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
all right let's cover a couple of other
things it is
an increasingly difficult job for the
lawyers that have been hired and i use
the term hired loosely because it's
never really clear that they're getting
paid the lawyers that have been hired by
donald trump to defend him and to make
the arguments in the court of public
opinion or in the media that will really
sway anybody now i've already said to
you before
the arguments they make on tv they often
will not make in a court of law and we
saw that over the last couple of days
but sometimes it gets to the point where
they don't even really have arguments
that they can make on tv and one of
donald trump's lawyers alina habba
appeared yesterday on newsmax and all
sorts of other media outlets
and nothing that she said was
particularly persuasive one of the
claims she tried to make in this first
clip
is that the reason trump's buildings are
worth so much more than many will
acknowledge
is because of the intangible
value raising
name recognition that calling a building
a trump building has now unfortunately
this isn't true but here's alina habba
trying to make this argument number one
number two when you have a trump
property that's a unicorn property
that's what we call that that's
something that has a brand that's what
we in the business call them value and
has
real estate value he's got some of the
best buildings in new york so you want
to sit there and tell me oh
trump do you know what a property's
worth it's worth what someone's willing
to pay for it it doesn't matter what
leticia james thinks now the only
problem with this argument
is that trump's properties
increasingly seem beleaguered by being
called trump whatever in fact remember
some of these stories
from when was this
from last year trump branded new york
building
looks to remove president's name
ex-president's name on tower
reduces its value this is the opposite
of the argument that alina habba is
making
other examples business insider from
2019 all the places that have removed
trump's name since he won in 2016.
and there's this whole list of places
um
two ice skating rinks
uh removed trump signs
nine other buildings remove trump signs
so it's just a lie in fact not only
might the trump name
not increase value it might diminish
value
here is um another one of these clips
where it she it just doesn't sound very
convincing we'll be ready to grow and we
will continue to crush it we're going to
continue to crush it it is what it is
it's an election political ploy here we
go leticia you know you made a mistake
you wanted to file but it's going to be
another l in your bucket here we go yeah
i'm not finding her super credible nor
super persuasive
here is um the same lawyer alina habba
on a different show on i guess this is
also newsmax this one's called rob
schmidt tonight
and again i'm not finding her arguments
particularly
i really think persuasive is the right
the right word now the department of
justice filed this crazy read
pretending it's all these criminal
actions because it's around the corner
to november and this is what we like to
call an october surprise which we've
seen before yeah so
it's an october surprise
in september
before a november
in which donald trump is not actually
running
hmm
it's not making a lot of sense elena and
of course one of the realities that
eventually we just start to bump up
against is
you can't always defend the indefensible
you just can't you get to a certain
point where okay listen you know what i
don't know i don't know between the
mar-a-lago thing and the georgia thing
and the january 6th thing and the new
york fraud thing and all of the other
things and the alleged rape thing and
all these
at some point you just can't keep
continue you can't continue defending
the indefensible and that's what trump's
lawyers are now up against and it's
quite a pleasure to see i have to tell
you
hopefully they're at least getting paid
which is a really tough thing to collect
when you are working for donald trump
hey this is uh i think some of you may
find this interesting
we launched the pacman finance channel
we announced this a while ago and i'll
remind you what that is in a moment
and the comments on this channel are
pure and utter gold where i am both
being called a socialist communist who
has no business talking about personal
finance
and also
being called a capitalist
who is bad
like alex jones says oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad and for that reason people aren't
going to watch the channel so let's back
it up a little bit
about a month and a half ago we
announced the forthcoming launch of the
pacman finance youtube channel this will
be a channel
it's not a political channel it's
personal finance
with
someone who is on the left
rather than like right-wing dave ramsey
so the way i like to think about pac-man
pac-man finance is it's like dave ramsey
but not a right-wing nut
not irrationally obsessed with avoiding
debt
and not anti-vaxx that that's the way
that's the elevator pitch for pacman
finance and it took us a while to get
this launched and we finally did
there are currently two videos up one
about building a logical asset
allocation
and another one for how to build an
emergency fund and the right order of
operations for one's finances
incredibly after just
24 48 hours of videos
we are already
at
3750 subscribers to this brand new
channel it's incredible i can't thank
people enough and you can find the
channel at youtube.com pacman finance
it's no frills
personal finance how to make a budget
why home prices and interest rates move
in opposite directions
index funds just basics okay
youtube.comfinance but the really
interesting thing is
i've been on politics youtube for a
decade and a half
and i know about the kind of toxic
nature of what's on politics youtube
now being exposed to finance youtube
it's absolutely fascinating check out
some of these comments that i spotted
our friend tommyboy
showed up
and said shouldn't you just wait for the
government to give you everything you
need to survive
i i don't know when i've ever advocated
for that and then tommy boy adding this
is comical a complete socialist talking
about asset allocation
laughable hypocrisy if you know anything
about me and my channels
it's that i am not a socialist i am a
social democrat that's a well regulated
type of capitalism so tommy boy is
confused then we continue
with people with a different perspective
sergeant salty showed up and said more
capitalist lies you can get rich too if
you follow this advice
that's not what i said you cannot find a
single place where i even imply that
sergeant salty goes on to say how about
instead of playing into the system
advocate for a new system that people
don't have to struggle to succeed in
well come over to my david pakman show
youtube channel
where i advocate for exactly that type
of change zephyrus commented i refuse to
watch capitalist content so some people
won't watch it because it's communist
and some people won't watch it because
it's capitalist okay a couple others
stig's journey said why is a communist
talking about finances
and then mr rembrandt said why would a
progressive anti-capitalist start a
finance channel
well
where are you getting that
i think capitalism is broken
but i'm not a socialist and i'm not a
communist and then lastly this is my
favorite
jason crawford asks a really good
question
what actual expertise do you have in
personal finance that's a fair question
i have an mba
specialized
in financial planning
that's my expertise and i hope that it
is suitable
uh folks
we've got a real problem out there so as
a reminder i will outline
i am an adherent to social democracy
i'm fine
with markets being used to direct
resources in some areas
broadcast microphones fine supply and
demand put it in the market
you know hipster sneakers
fine
but i want certain areas out of that
when we talk about healthcare
when we talk about education there are
certain things i don't think should be
subjected to vulture capitalism and the
whims of the market everybody should
have a home
everybody should have health care
everybody should have food we can do
these things okay
and
as a social democrat which is a
well-regulated form of capitalism i
believe that we should use
taxation on the very rich
to ensure
that nobody drops below
a certain level a certain standard of
living
we should be funding
maternity and paternity leave we should
be using those funds to make sure that
we are taking care of people
the rich can still be rich but the
richer you get we're going to take a
bigger and bigger slice
to make sure everybody's doing okay
if you want to call that socialism
you're wrong
if you want to call that unregulated
capitalism you're also wrong we're
talking about a regulated form of
capitalism okay so that's the deal we
don't do politics on the finance channel
we do the politics here but again i
encourage you to go to
youtube.compacmanfinance
be one of the first 5 000 subscribers
it's free guys it's completely free
next video comes out today we've got
another video coming out tomorrow it's
an absolutely fantastic thing we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
david p now i'm going to do something
potentially against my better judgment
i am going to play a voicemail from this
uh very insistent troll troy york now
some of you might say that rings a bell
troy york where do i know that name troy
york has been calling into the show and
leaving voicemails for years and years
and years
and months ago maybe even longer i just
stopped playing his voicemails because
they got so boring and pedantic and
pointless you didn't like them i didn't
like them they didn't bring anything
interesting to the table recently people
have been saying whatever happened to
troy york well what happened to troy
york is that he still leaves two to
three voicemails a day
haven't played his voicemail for months
maybe longer but he is insistently
leaving voicemail after voicemail half
of them you can barely hear what he says
his connection's a disaster the
background noises is just infuriating
but i want to play one voicemail
just to show you
this is really what happens when your
brain is completely scrambled on right
wing talking points and confusion and
you're in a daze where you completely
lack any ability to think critically or
for yourself about anything and as often
as the case troy york uses up the full
three-minute max on our voicemail line
let's just see how far we can get
through this but understand this is your
brain on idiocy
uh david patterning uh more
lies of the corrupt mainstream media
through their polling
um continue to
meddle and rock into the pennsylvania um
senate election and recontinued life and
abuse
of polling is something that um there
needs to be rocking with these polls
mean absolutely nothing
and are meant to manipulate the votes
they always favor the democrats well
right now john fetterman is up four in
polling in pennsylvania and ron desantis
is up five in polling in florida
so
if we can't believe any of the polling
then certainly on election day
both of the results in those races
should differ from the polling we'll be
able to test that in just a few weeks um
they are partisan in nature they're
untrustworthy
they are deceiving and they should be
declared illegal um anyone with a brain
that's a really conservative light touch
right make polling illegal
would ignore these polls but naturally
you are like the scarecrow from the land
of oz you do not have a brain um that
functions properly
your brain mr david packman is a butter
it's but it's not mayonnaise it's butter
listen um i mean poles are generally
speaking pretty accurate you know you go
back to 2020 the polling going in had
biden like plus five
and biden ended up winning by 7.2
um
it's really pretty close in 2016 uh let
me see if i can 2016
trump hillary i'll get the exact numbers
for us in 2016 the polling had hillary
up three and hillary won the popular
vote by two now of course we have this
crazy system called an electoral college
and it led to trump winning the
electoral vote but the popular vote
polls said hillary plus three hillary
one by two
the polling is generally speaking pretty
accurate joy you are so
deranged with trump's syndrome
you are so delusional with your
progressive radical extremism yeah
um you can't even
call off these poles for the horse
manure that they are um
dr amendment oz is by far a healthier
stronger
more
more competent um
person i can't speak to the comparison
between oz and fetterman on physical
health but oz is in way over his head
betterman's a really brilliant guy
harvard lieutenant governor etc
oz doesn't know up from down and left
from right more competent
leader than john fetterman who is a
disgrace he is a scum he looks like the
average homeless guy
he can't dress he can't talk he has no
ability to live a healthy lifestyle he
doesn't care
the man is
morbidly obese unhealthy i actually do
don't think fetterman's morbidly obese
anyway so that's troy york that'll be
the one voicemail for the year he'll
keep calling in you know two to three
times a day but that for those of you
have been wondering it's still the same
drivel we have a great bonus show for
you today
jenny thomas the wife of supreme court
justice clarence thomas
we'll be speaking with the house january
6th panel when and under what terms we
will discuss
the woman who falsely accused the black
bird watcher remember that wacky story
and then got fired
she sued her ex-employer and has lost
the lawsuit we will talk about it many
are calling it sweet justice i'm not
calling it that but many people are
and the world cup captains want to wear
rainbow armbands in qatar i have to tell
you
the rainbow armbands are fine
but the stadiums were built by
essentially slave labor
so this is one of those things where
yeah
fine but we're kind of missing the
forest for the trees we're going to talk
about all of those stories and more when
producer pat joins me on today's bonus
show you can get instant access to the
bonus show by signing up at
joinpackman.com
and remember we have launched the new
youtube channel pacman finance
youtube.compacmanfinance
subscribe free
the clips are going update we'll see you
then